Teheran gestern Abend Iraner wacht auf
wehrt euch rufen die Demonstranten sie
fordern das Regime weiter heraus
Brandsätze und sprechöre in vielen
Städten des Landes wie hier in nuschar
am Kaspischen Meer wo eine junge Frau am
Samstag von Sicherheitskräften
erschossen wurde
ich habe großen Respekt vor diesen
jungen Menschen so der Oscar-Preisträger
fahadi sie kämpfen für ihre Freiheit
ihre Art zu leben trotz der ganzen
Brutalität die sie erleiden
keine Gnade mit aller härtevorgehen so
die Befehle an die Polizisten und die
bewaffneten Schläger der militärischen
Hilfstruppen basiert laut Amnesty
International werde auch vorsätzlich auf
Demonstranten geschossen
die wollen unsere islamische Revolution
Schwächen sagt der Polizeichef aber
nicht mit uns wir tragen diese Uniform
hier wir verteidigen die Revolution und
das Volk
überprüfen lassen sich die meisten
Videos nicht das Internet wurde
weitgehend gesperrt Journalistinnen und
Journalisten werden verhaftet wenn sie
über Proteste berichten
stattdessen möchte das Regime solche
Bilder zeigen Trauerfeier von
Regierungsanhängern für ein Mitglied der
bassid-gruppen das bei den Demos getötet
wurde mindestens 41 Menschen kamen
bislang ums Leben die meisten
Demonstranten für Irans Machthaber ist
klar wo die Schuldigen sitzen in USA und
Israel Präsident reisi besuchte heute
verletzte Sicherheitsbeamte er will die
Proteste wie üblich mit Gewalt
niederknüppeln lassen zu viel steht für
die korrupten Machthaber auf dem Spiel
die Behörden bestreiten außerdem weiter
das masseamini die Kurdin die vor zwei
Wochen im Polizeigewahrsam starb
geschlagen wurde
für den Vetter des Opfers erfahren der
im Exil in Irak liegt ist das eine
glatte Lüge sie wollten Massas Leiche
heimlich nachts verscharren sagt er das
haben die Dorfbewohner verhindert
und dann haben sie ihre Eltern gezwungen
über all das zu schweigen und nicht mit
den Medien zu sprechen
das Regime hat als vermeintliches
Zeichen der Stärke seine Anhänger für
morgen im ganzen Land zu Demonstrationen
aufgerufen
und wir fragen nach bei unserem
Korrespondenten für die Region Lück
walport schönen guten Tag noch mal nach
Istanbul worum geht es jetzt bei den
Protesten geht es noch um die Rechte der
Frauen und das Kopftuch oder geht es
schon um weit mehr
es geht auch um die Rechte der Frauen es
geht aber generell um Bürgerrechte und
damit auch um weit mehr denn die Schärfe
auch der Reaktion insbesondere der
jungen Bevölkerung auf dieses Regime hat
entschieden zugenommen weit mehr als das
noch bei den
größtenteils wirtschaftlich begünneten
Unruhen 2019 war vor drei Jahren also
das nimmt ein Schärfe zu und es ist auch
immer deutlicher das große Teile
insbesondere der Jugend in Iran
überhaupt keine Hoffnung mehr sehen mit
diesem Regime mit dieser Islamischen
Republik weitermachen zu wollen also das
ist grundsätzlich das merken die
Machthaber auch das hat eine neue
Qualität bekommen natürlich geht es
vielen Iranerinnen auch um ihre eigenen
Freiheitsrechte insbesondere jetzt darum
diese unsinnige Kleiderordnung über Bord
zu werfen aber das Regime hat schon
angedeutet dass es da im Moment
überhaupt keine flexible Situation gibt
also man wird an dieser Kleiderordnung
festhalten und versuchen diese Proteste
wie in der Vergangenheit mit Gewalt
zurückzuschlagen klar ist die rheinische
ist mehr denn je ganz tief gespalten
zwischen denen die nicht teilhaben an
der Macht auch an der ökonomischen also
am Geld und die eine andere Republik
wollen und denen die diese Republik so
wie sie ist mit aller Korruption und all
der unverteilung von Geld und Vermögen
weiter daran festhalten Einschätzung von
unserem Korrespondenten lycalport vielen
Dank
[Musik]